okay Treecko you know that Torchic  doesn't like water morning  pokemon battle begin thanks a good taco  bell quick Treecko use pound the three  Hoenn region first partner Pokemon  Treecko the wood gecko Pokemon  Georgie the chick pokemon ya take  and Mudkip the mudfish Pokemon  Pokemon gets stronger as they gain  experience in battle and finally evolve  and the deep and lasting bond that is  created between trainer and Pokemon  makes them even stronger beyond  evolution mega evolve  mega Sceptile mega Blaziken  mega Swampert  mega Zion see mega-girl a mega salamence  mega pidgeot  mega clearly mega steelix mega cameras  mega Beedrill mega slow bro mega  Sharpedo megalopolis mega Sableye mega  I'll toria mega audino  alright let's begin mega Metagross  mega latios and mega latios  primal Groudon  primal Kyogre  mega rayquaza explore the mysteries of  mega evolution in Pokemon Omega Ruby and  alpha sapphire  you